ever wonder why ninety percent of sales
people don't make it within five years
meaning real estate insurance it doesn't
matter what you do five years later
ninety percent don't make it only one
out of ten makes so why is that by the
way i wanna manage expectations with you
most people who get into sales they have
no idea how hard it is this thing is
hard so if you're not in the mood for
somebody to scare you off from sales
skip this video but if you want the
truth i'm going to give it to you today
[Music]
so stick around till the very end to get
the pdf of today's content as well as
tips on how to make it past your five
years but let me get right into it first
five warnings five things you need to
know about before you get into sales
number one it's harder than you think by
the way 10 times harder than you think
mentally emotionally it's going to be
frustrating agitating you're going to go
through it you'll be tested you don't
want to call people back because people
didn't call you back four times you have
to learn the script of words it's so
annoying at first because it's harder
you're not accustomed to it number two
it takes a lot longer to make money than
you think some industries are different
but it takes a lot longer for you to
make money than you think point number
three you're gonna make a lot less money
at first than you think by the way most
people get into sales because somebody
sold them a dream right oh my god i want
to have that guy's life i wanted to
because somebody told me to dream i want
to one day have the life and the cars
and travel and freedom and all this
other stuff right and what you don't
realize is that guy paid the price for
many many years until he had the
lifestyle that he has today so for you
manage expectations knowing at first
you're gonna be underpaid for a long
time and don't be disappointed we all go
through that phase number four you're
gonna have a lot of sleepless nights
thinking about sales you're gonna go to
sleep saying oh my god is this person
gonna buy tomorrow what if they change
their minds this person change our minds
what do i do with this i was expecting
this thousand dollar commission what am
i gonna do to pay my bills here i need
to give him you're gonna go through
those nights the anxiety mental
emotional it's tough you're gonna go
through it and last but not least your
friends family spouse everyone's gonna
ask you how much money have you made how
much money have you made how much money
have you ever had how much why are you
doing this why did you start to do this
you had a good job why did you choose it
everybody's going to ask you and this
whole test of these five warnings i gave
you
you're supposed to go through it here's
why
once you make it past these five areas
and you overcome it your skin is thicker
you can handle more you become a leader
and somehow someway based on your work
ethic you improving you're getting
better attitude all of that stuff all of
a sudden the floodgates open in sales
for you and you wake up and you say i
never thought this is what was going to
happen to me that's kind of what
happened to me but you got to go through
it so if you're still sticking around to
watch the content let me share with you
what things you could do to help you win
the game of sales especially after your
first year number one if you're going to
do sales
go and seek out the best leader worth
duplicating the market's filled with a
lot of average sales people the market's
filled with a lot of average sales
leaders but the market's also filled
with a lot of great sales people and
great sales leaders you find the right
sales leaders worth duplicating the
chances of you winning not only
increases but the speed and how quickly
you win also increases so choose an
industry say you're going to do real
estate you're going to do digital
marketing insurance finance stocks
whatever it is fine choose that industry
stay in that industry don't keep jumping
industry to industry to industry rather
within that industry seek out the best
mentors to work with so that's point
number one and the tip you're gonna get
number two is the following
since you know
and i know that this thing's gonna be
hard mentally and emotionally
what worked for me is over and over and
over again i read autobiographies and
content about people that persevered
like even this one the book of the month
for my sales guys i have 20 000 plus
insurance agents this one the book we're
reading is a book called endurance this
is a book about you lasting this is a
book about you being able to go through
tough times you need to feed yourself so
much of that because your friends your
family your cousins your girlfriend your
boyfriend your husband your wife they're
all putting so much fear babe why are
you doing this babe why don't you go
back to your job they want to go back to
you need to you need to almost fight off
all that negativity with positivity they
can make it in sales point number three
whatever product you're selling do
whatever you can to sell yourself on the
product before i give you point number
four if you were in the sales office i
was in encino from 2002 until 2005
you would have found me all over the
office with a role play buddy role
playing script it didn't matter what it
was we would role play scripts and
objections
we'd sit in a room for one hour after
nine o'clock at night while everybody
else was gone and i would give an
objection and you'd overcome it
then i'm like i can't i think we can
come out with a better way to overcome
it i would give it you would give it i
would give it you would give it oh that
was good then we write it down and so
let me try this one how about this one
how about well that's the perfect one
how about that how about this how about
that we roll plates so much until any
objection that people ask throughout the
day i could do my eyes closed i can do
it with my eyes closed today even though
it was in 2003 2004 so find yourself a
role play buddy and role play with them
constantly until you can overcome all
the major objections without even
thinking about them point number five
when it comes down to prospecting too
many times people all they think about
what prospect is let me send an email on
linkedin let me dm this person let me go
out there and prospect that any man let
me do some business let me do this let
me do that right so everybody they look
at as a customer but i want to kind of
give you a complete different
perspective there's nothing wrong with
looking at everybody as a customer
but think about it this way okay
imagine you like this 22 year old girl
okay and you're 25 26 years old and you
want to date her and you go into a room
and you spot her okay
so she's the customer like i want her
she's the customer right okay no problem
then there is a 58 year old woman over
here you have no interest in because all
you're thinking about is a 22 year old
but what you don't know is
that 58 year old woman
is her
mentor her mom her auntie that she
admires the most that if you win her
she'll put in a good ward into the 22
year old and then she's gonna go on a
date with you because she'll make the
introduction so rather than going 22 you
go to the 58 year old you talk to her
you get what can i get you something
ma'am is there anything i can get you oh
wow you're so sweet yeah you know what i
would like them no problem let me get
you a drink here you go thank you enjoy
your evening and you walk away that that
fellow right there got me a drink why
didn't i say hey let me introduce you to
my niece let me introduce you and then
boom so pat where are you going with
this here's where i'm going with this
i would go networking
for my main referral source
influencers okay
and i took care of them as much as i
could whatever they wanted i took care
of them because i knew
they were going to lead me
to the customers that i wanted not just
once not just twice not just three times
for for years and years and years and
years to come so going back to it as
much as it's great to think about
prospecting as and let me go get the
client
think about prospecting as a let me find
the influencers that can introduce me to
customers for years and years and years
to come point number six is try to
redefine in your own mind like think
about when you think about what a
salesperson looks like and how they work
and how they talk
try to redefine that like oh to be great
in sales you have to be a car salesman
no it's and there's nothing wrong with
that but no that's not the personality
when you think about a salesperson to me
a great salesperson
is one who asks the right question is a
great listener who's coming from a place
of wanting to help you
as the individual that may be different
than others and is able to tailor
something that matches your needs right
so think of sales that way don't think
of sales
as somebody who you know has all
everything is just perfect and put
together and all this stuff you know i
got a three-piece suit on right now
because i'm shooting the video with you
but believe me i'm a guy that just went
out there and i looked in and said i
wonder how i can help this person let me
you know this person is slightly
different than the other client i sat
down with man i if they understood this
product
and if they said they want this this can
be so hey you know what after spending a
lot of time here's what i think would be
a great uh product for you these are the
different things we can look at but this
is what i felt was great for you but i
want to open it up what questions do you
have on these products before i make the
recommendations this one i think is good
for you're taking a very consultative
approach then just a slam dunk i got to
be able to be the best sales person and
push them and i got gotta make them sign
the check that's in the movies
and quite frankly those types of sales
people maybe worked in the 60s 70s 80s
they don't work that well today and even
if you close you ain't never going to
get referrals and this whole name of the
game is referrals so sales people like
that
rarely be customers become be backs and
rarely do those customers give referrals
you want a lot of referrals so redefine
your image of what a sales person looks
like this next one's pretty much a story
by life and it has to do with follow-up
my confidence comes from follow-up if
you asked anybody that ever did business
with me they'll tell you pat's biggest
strength who work with me closing sales
pat's biggest strength and sales just
follow up here's why
did you know
80 of customers who buy
they'll say yes but you got to follow up
five times before they say yes but did
you also know 44 of salespeople don't
follow up after the first time they
don't hear back from the client let me
say this one more time 80 of sales
requires five follow-up calls before
they say yes and you fill out the
paperwork
44 of the time sales people don't follow
up after the first call so they leave a
message ah man she's not interested how
do you know uh they didn't pick up or
call me back so wait let me get this
straight to you you define that as
they're not interested oh yeah of course
if they were interested they'd call me
back are you kidding me let me ask you a
question how many times like right now
while i'm sitting here i got two texts
i'm telling these guys i gotta go make
these texts right i clicked on the text
it shows it's read i may forget about it
after this meeting because i'm in the
middle of something and if that person
doesn't follow up this text may be lost
in translation and that could end up
being business for one of the people
right now that just texted me right
we make that mistake you don't know that
person forgot to call you back that
person maybe no longer checks messages
or emails or texts but you got to keep
following up don't be discouraged when
somebody says no or doesn't follow up
with you or doesn't call you back don't
take it personal this isn't the dating
game where you call them and you don't
want to call too many times to seem
desperate you definitely don't want to
be overly pestering your customer but
you do want to be a smooth operator and
keep following up because chances are
they'll eventually do business with you
so you made it to the very end even
though i gave you the warnings even
though i try to scare you off you still
want more tips no problem more power to
you today's content isn't a pdf as well
as three additional bonus tips below if
you click on the link below you'll be
able to get that pdf on top of that i
did talk about referrals if you want to
get better at referrals i made a video
about a year and a half ago or so maybe
a year ago that gets into referrals in a
very deep way if you've never watched it
click over here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]